Most conversations online about ideology seem
to be like a lame snowball fight, with people
lobbing tweets, insults, and MS Paint memes
at each other.
And you’re probably wondering “there has
to be a better way!”
And neuroscience says, there just might be.
Theme song time!
We're just going to do this next paragraph then.
Let’s use the 1996 original motion picture,
Space Jam as an example.
Now, if you don’t like Space Jam, well,
yeah, of course I’m gonna give you the hands,
because that movie’s fire, and you suck for not believing
what I believe.
If I want you to believe what I believe, I
have to find a better way than that to influence you
and there have been studies done to find the
most effective way to persuade people.
Have you gotten into a fight on Facebook,
brought up a source, and someone STILL refused
to change their mind?
Well, a 1979 study had participants with strong
opinions on the death penalty, both for and against,
look at two articles; one backing
up their point of view, the other contradicting it.
And the study found that participants only
agreed with the study that supported their
stance, further polarizing the groups.
We call this a confirmation bias.
Basically, we only want to believe facts that
help prove that we’re right.
So, if you think Space Jam is trash, which
you absolutely shouldn’t, and I just throw articles
about the cultural impact, the amazing soundtrack,
and how hard it is to act on green screen
with people who aren’t Bugs Bunny, then
I probably won’t change your mind.
But why are we like this?
Some researchers think it’s because humans
have developed a reasoning mechanism, not
to get to the truth but just to convince people
that we’re right because being wrong feels
like a failure and everyone prefers that victory
of being right.
But there might be a way to combat this.
Mad people get emotionally invested in fights
on the internet, at Thanksgiving, on the internet
at Thanksgiving, and sometimes (most times)
it doesn’t work out.
Emotion is a powerful tool to change another
person’s mind, but how?
A Princeton MRI study found that when a group
of people listen to a powerful political speech,
their brains ticked together; there was a
synchronization effect.
Which makes sense, everyone’s attention was on it.
But what was synchronizing?
Their emotions.
A 2004 study found further evidence when they
had subjects watch 30 minutes of a movie and
their brains synced up at most emotional
beats in the movie.
Humans respond to emotional stimuli, so using
emotions to drive a point home is important;
our brain’s structure, functions, and expression
are similar, so responsibly sharing my feelings
on Space Jam while Evanescence’s “My Immortal"
(a banger) plays in the background, might work.
Positive and constructive ways to persuade
people to your point of view are much easier,
especially when you try to find common ground.
All right, so if common ground and emotional appeal aren’t working, give up, right? I would.
Not exactly.
Say you really care about an issue, particularly
one with social relevance.
Human instinct is to take to the streets and
hope people really care about your issue,
and it’s frustrating when they don’t, right?
Well, it’s all about framing.
In Tali Sharot’s book, The Influential Mind, she uses the example of airline safety videos.
If the video says, “y’all better chill
before this plane crashes!”
Well, that's dark and bleak and people wouldn't respond
well to that; that’s why preflight safety
videos are much more lit now, with breakdancers,
rappers, and whatever else will elicit a more
positive feeling while delivering the same
message.
In a politically polarized time, it’s easy
to sit back on what we believe and not engage
with other points of view, but I just want
people to remember that our brains are very
similar to each others, and we all respond
to how information is packaged.
Now, I’m not saying, engage with racists,
sexists, homophobes, Nickelback apologists,
on the internet and don’t engage with
people who make you feel like you’re arguing
for your right to exist and your humanity.
I’m just saying that while we’re hoping
for progress, we should think about how we
frame information.
We have a degree of mental elasticity and
the brain has space for change
if we allow it to.
Remember, we’re not going to win every argument;
sometimes rhyme and reason doesn’t sway someone,
so it’s gucci if you’re like “yeah,
not today” and take care of yourself.
Might I suggest curling up with some popcorn, maybe a chamomile tea and enjoy a delightful romp
starring Michael Jordan and Bugs Bunny perhaps?
There's a lot of political noise out there and you might prefer a little bit of silence.
So if you want to know what's better for your brain, noise or silence, check this video out right over here.
Be sure to subscribe to Seeker and thank you for watching.